bonjour jean marie théodat merci de
répondre à nos questions jouvenel mo is
a donc été assassiné par un commando qui
peuvent être ces hommes armés par qui
qui aurait pu commandité cet assassinat
alors malheureusement la situation est
tellement confuse analytique
il ya tellement de jacky ce prime peut
profiter qu'il est difficile de
l'assigner à tel ou tel groupe
le fait est que le pays est ravagé
depuis plusieurs mois par des activités
de gangs de gangsters qui ont établi
leurs quartiers dans plusieurs secteurs
de la capitale qui sont complètement qui
échappe totalement au contrôle de l'état
c'est pour ça que le premier ministre a
dit que la situation sécuritaire est
sous contrôle jaugeant doute
personnellement et de sorte que nous
sommes dans une confusion totale nous ne
pouvons pas véritablement à signer ce
crime
un groupe ou un autre quand vous dites
vous doutez que la situation sécuritaire
soit sous contrôle ça veut dire qu'il
faut s'attendre à quoi désormais selon
vous des drs qui sont à craindre dans
les rues de port au prince la capitale
ce que vous l'avez dire le pays est
gangrené par la violence par la
corruption les enlèvements contre rançon
par des gangs sont sont monnaie courante
tout à fait je veux dire que la
situation ne peut pas être pire qu'elle
l'était avant parce que depuis plusieurs
semaines les faits car certains
quartiers de port au prince sont
pratiquement interdite d'accès donc pire
que cela
c'était c'est la situation que nous
venons de vivre c'est à dire que la
situation sécuritaire aujourd'hui à
déborder les limites même les limites
symbolique du pouvoir donc que c'est
l'état qui est ici attaquer et ça veut
dire que nous ne pouvons pas tomber plus
bas
il peut y avoir encore des violences ces
prochaines heures dans les rues
je me permets d'en douter de la mesure
ce n'est pas une insurrection armée ce
ne sont pas des groupes avec une base
sociale qui pourrait effectivement
mobiliser des gens pour aller soit à
s'attaquer aux partisans du président ou
moins soit loué à s'attaquer à ce qu'il
doit signer je pense que il y à une
consternation qui frappe l'ensemble du
pays et pour les heures à venir il est
extrêmement hasardeux d'avoir un
pronostic de dire ce qui va se passer
une fois très prudent qui va diriger le
pays par intérim maintenant que prévoit
la constitution haïtienne est ce que de
nouvelles élections vont avoir lieu
prochainement
nous devions avoir des élections cet
automne pour l'élection d'un nouveau
président la constitution remanié de
1987 fait du premier ministre le
président de fait de delà du pays or le
président dont le premier ministre
actuel donc mes chers ariel henry a été
nommé il ya seulement trois jours il
n'est pas encore passé devant la chambre
parce que il n'y a pas de représentation
d'initiative actuellement c'est à dire
que tous les voyants sont au rouge dans
ce pays le président est mort le premier
ministre qui est censé le remplacer
n'est pas encore formellement investi et
puis nous n'avons aucune aucune force de
sécurité capable vraiment de contrôler
la situation ou même d'arrêter les
assassins
parce que dans le fond si on a pu entrer
dans l'enceinte du pouvoir à dire dans
la résidence privée du président pour
l'assassiner cela veut dire que personne
ne contrôle plus rien comment peut et
comment va réagir la communauté
internationale on sait qu'à la maison
blanche qui a déjà réagi qui condamne un
acte je cite terrible malheureusement
nous n'avons pas de grand-chose à
attendre la communauté nationale si ce
n'est donc des prises de positions
lénifiantes parce que cela fait des mois
que la situation pourrie en haïti on n'a
jamais vu un onglet l'épée nord ceux qui
sont sensés
les mentors du pouvoir mal qui je parle
de ce qu'on appelle le coron en haïti
personne ne s'est véritablement de
prononcer pour me dire au président de
mettre fin à sa dérive dictatoriale ni
pour essayer de mettre fin à l'activité
de gangs en haïti est un pays qu elle s
on a laissé courir dans une sorte de
point aujourd'hui la pourriture ne
remonte au nez et c'est un peu tard pour
don magnifique personnel dunyach en
haïti a pour langues officielles
évidemment le créole haïtien mais
également le français un lien
particulier unit paris à port-au-prince
quel rôle à présent pour la france la
fois saluer rôle historique très
important en tant qu'ancienne puissance
comme il y aller en tant que pays
partageant le même patrimoine
linguistique culturelle que nous mais
malheureusement haïti fait partie de la
sphère d influence américaine et la
france n'a pas véritablement moyens de
renverser la tendance
bien entendu sa voix est toujours très
entendu très respecté en haïti mais la
politique étrangère de la france une ne
considère pas haïti comme un pays du
champ donc malheureusement nous sommes
seuls face à l'adversité
merci jean marie théodat pour ces mots
forts vous êtes géographe spécialiste
d'haïti est maître de conférences à
l'université panthéon sorbonne